hello and welcome to the take with
safety ridge we are here live in downing
street this evening and behind that door
the future of the prime minister is
being decided it's no exaggeration to
say that it's been an unprecedented day
39 mps have now resigned from his
administration a flood started by rishi
sunak and sajid javed that now courses
through every level of government and
there have been some extraordinary
scenes this evening as cabinet ministers
went into number 10 and told the prime
minister that he has to go a delegation
including two of the people who have
only been in their jobs for just a
single day
well lots to get through this evening
here we are told that boris johnson is
defiant and will not resign we're going
to be bringing you the very latest on
the future of the prime minister over
the next 60 minutes
[Music]
good evening a defiance boris johnson
this evening stands on the very brink
today alone he's lost 14 ministers no
other prime minister in history has lost
so many in a single day and this evening
senior members of his cabinet went into
that building to say the game is up even
including we're told the home secretary
pretty patel someone always so loyal to
boris johnson but boris johnson is
himself is saying that he is digging in
he is continuing to fight there could be
a reshuffle number 10 has been clear
given that looks like given that it
looks like we could be heading for yet
another conservative party vote of no
confidence very soon
it comes after a quite extraordinary two
days let's start with a quick look at
what has got us to this point
yes i think it was a mistake and i
apologize for
for it i think in in hindsight it was
the wrong thing to do i apologize to
everybody who's been badly affected
we're just hearing that uh
sajid javid has resigned
the chancellor of the extracurricular
has now resigned there's been seven more
resignations in junior post just hearing
that there's been another resignation
let me just check um who it is
laura trott we've also had a resignation
letter from the junior education
minister will quince in the last few
minutes the school's minister robin
robin walker has resigned as well alec
we've got another resignation felicity
buckin pps to the business department
today is a big day as we implement the
biggest tax cut
as we implement the biggest tax cut for
a decade he knew
the accused minister had previously
committed predatory behavior but he
promoted him to a position of power
anyway
why
anyone quitting now
after defending all that hasn't got a
shred of integrity he talks about in
integrity he wanted he wanted to install
uh the member for islington north into
number 10. as for those who are left
only in office because no one else is
prepared to debase themselves any longer
the charge of the lightweight brigade
six others voted to get rid of our
independent nuclear deterrent and mr
speaker today we are cutting taxes i
have concluded that the problem starts
at the top and i believe that is not
going to change and that
means that it is for those of us in a
position who have responsibility to make
that change did you say picture by name
picture by nature i i'm not going to
get into some uh trivializing discussion
of what i may or may not have said it's
being reported that there's a
delegation of your cabinet colleagues
waiting in downing street including the
chief whip the transport secretary and
your new chancellor
waiting to tell you when you finish here
today that it's time for you to go how
will you respond to that i'm not going
to give her a running commentary on
political events we're going to get on
with the government of the country i've
reluctantly come to the conclusion that
there is an issue with alcohol well i
mean you're the last person in the room
to accept that there's a problem if you
have lost the confidence of your mps and
you're required to step down as leader
of the conservative party you will not
seek to dissolve parliament
well
this country needs the lord because
we're lasting for there's this house but
this happens but i'm not going to step
down and the last thing this country
needs frankly is election the story is
developing here there is a greeting
party here of senior cabinet members and
they will be wanting to talk to him i've
been told that uh priti patel has spoken
to the prime minister this evening where
she's conveyed to him the overwhelming
views of the parliamentary
party and we know what the overwhelming
view of the parties is that he should go
what we understand is that the prime
minister remains defiant he is not going
to stand down he is going to continue
imposed and try to keep this government
going
well what an extraordinary
couple of days we have had it's just
gone 9pm on wednesday evening here in
downing street where exactly are we
right now let's try and find out we're
joined now by our deputy political
editor
sam
coates
the prime minister's digging in that's
right
what a day more than
115 conservative mps over the last
pretty much 24 hours a bit more than 24
hours now have made clear they think
boris johnson should leave government
you've got 39 ministers resigning from
government now
mid this afternoon the word from the
rebels were we've done our job we have
shown the breadth and depth of the
opposition to boris johnson it's now for
the cabinet
to do the last few heavy lifting yards
and a delegation went in lots of the
biggest names uh went in behind that
door uh including pretty patel including
brandon lewis including simon hart the
world secretary and a number of others
all of which uh went in to tell the
prime minister the time was up now one
more name was amongst them that was
nadine zahawi he was only appointed as
chancellor something short of 10 o'clock
last night already the rebels believed
he had flipped after criticism from his
allies and was going in to tell the
prime minister as well along with all
those other cabinet figures that he
thought that that
meant that his time was up but tonight
we understand after many conversations
number 10 believe that they are pulling
nadine zahavi who at the moment is a
critical figure in this government in
the tussle between those who want to
keep boris johnson those want to out
oust him there are just signs that
nadine sahar who may have been persuaded
to stay on side working through a new
economic plan together with andrew
griffith the advisor had a policy inside
number 10 and so boris johnson will use
that and his claim that his power comes
from the people the 40 million who
elected him in the 2019 general election
to keep him in place extraordinary
really and i guess this is the moment we
find out if the threats the cabinet to
resign are actually going to come true
or not whether they're prepared to lose
their jobs i spoke to one cabinet going
in there saying he said i've got my
letter in my pocket of resignation i'll
use it it'll be me or him uh quitting
their job tonight well neither of them
have as of 10 past nine
and it depends on whether or not you can
rely on mp's backbone so often not quite
doing what they say but if there are
vacancies there'll be a reshuffle
tonight
much more turbulence even uh coming on
the rest of today absolutely
extraordinary stuff sam thank you very
much we'll be keeping of course a very
keen eye
on the comings and goings in that door
behind us what are the conversations
being had has as sam said anyone started
to flip from one side to another every
member of the cabinet right now counts
when it comes to the survival of boris
johnson well let's speak now to our
chief political correspondent john craig
at shall we who is live in westminster
for us in our uh millbank studio uh john
what is the word coming from allies of
boris johnson
well i got a statement uh sophie from uh
james daddridge he is the mp for uh
rochford and south end west and he is
the prime minister's parliamentary
private secretary or one of them and he
has given sky news an on the record
quote about the prime minister's
defiance mr duddridge has told sky news
the prime minister is in buoyance mood
and will fight on
he has a 14 million mandate obviously a
reference to the general election and so
much to do for the country
i expect him to make senior cabinet
appointments this evening and i'm
looking forward to hearing what the pm
and his fantastic chancellor nadeem
zahawi have to say tomorrow now that was
about half an hour ago
now uh mr duddridge has just been in
touch to say
the economic plan is next week not
tomorrow uh change of plan it seems so
from the prime minister's one of his
inner circle uh the prime minister is in
buoyant mood we're told we'll fight on
talking about his mandate from the
electorate much to do as he said it
pmq's and in the liaison committee now
intriguingly mr duddridge says i expect
the pm to make senior cabinet
appointments this evening so um
as far as i know uh we don't haven't had
it confirmed of any more cabinet
resignations as yet uh we know that uh
mr uh uh sunak's job has been filled by
mr zu zahawi as we've just been
discussing and sajid jobs posters health
sector has been filled by steve barkley
and as for the uh economic plan well
there is going to be an economic plan
but not tomorrow is the very latest
information it's coming next week um mr
sunak and the prime minister were due to
launch an economic plan together they
wrote a joint article in the sun on
sunday at the weekend uh but um
now it's of course uh it is the the new
chancellor nadeem zahawi let me just
bring you some other intelligence from
uh inside the houses of parliament uh i
spoke to one very senior mp who had been
briefed by a senior member of the
cabinet who went in to talk to the pm
and told him go now and that minister
was saying how shocked they were when he
said to them no i'm not going
i spoke to a minister another minister
who quit uh yesterday uh sorry earlier
today and that minister said no when i
said that the pm was refusing to go
another minister though who still
imposed said to me
when i told him that that the minister
was the prime minister was refusing to
go said well we'll see how long that
holds now i also interviewed a short
time ago on sky news steve reed the
shadow justice secretary speaking on
behalf of the labour party it seems that
uh sir sakirshama will have discussions
with the likes of ian blackford who i
also spoke to here on sky news about a
motion of no confidence in the prime
minister if by next week he is refusing
to budge and another point tomorrow
there are concerns about how the
business is going to work in parliament
given so many ministers have resigned
its culture media and sport questions
one at least one minister from there has
resigned um and there's only nadine
doris left uh in that department and the
solicitor general's gone just on the eve
of um
of um
of attorney general's question so unless
the prime minister fills a lot of
vacancies tonight there's gonna be some
empty uh a lot of empty spaces on the
green benches in the commons tomorrow
but the big news is the prime minister
is buoyant and will fight on that is
confirmed by his parliamentary private
secretary on the record
okay john craig thank you very much
indeed john craig air reporting for us
there and i think as john was saying it
feels like we do still have a prime
minister but the question is do we still
have a government with all those
resignations uh certainly a top of the
entree for number 10 to fill some of
those posts and do it quickly
if he is to try and plow on
now our next guest there was some pretty
stinging words in the letter that he
published earlier on today honesty and
integrity should be the watchwords of
all politicians i no longer believe
after several resets that these values
can be re-embedded under the current
leadership well that was the
conservative mp alex shelbrook's stark
criticism of the prime minister today as
he announced that he wanted boris
johnson to go he joins us as now we can
speak to him thank you very much for
being with us uh mr shelbrook and
why did you change your mind
yeah good evening sophie um so i've
tried to remain um a step back and um
look at things stoically um but in prime
minister's questions today i i just felt
it has just gone in through the door of
at number 10 brandon lewis there the
northern ireland secretary widely
reported to be part of the delegation
calling on the prime minister to quit
now he's been on a flight a delayed
flight actually uh from northern ireland
which perhaps explains why he was late
going into the doors of number 10
no words for the reporters at shouting
questions but brandon lewis there
just going into the doors of number 10
behind us we will give you any updates
we can for what is going on behind those
doors but in the meantime go back to
alex shell brick apologies for the
interruption it's one of those uh nights
i think uh very fluent uh down here
outside number 10
this evening you were saying why you've
changed your mind on whether or not
boris johnson should remain as prime
minister
yes thank you sophie and it was prime
minister's questions um
he seemed to have some strange views as
to why chris pincher was in the job and
he he started to say you know i didn't
want him there and i don't understand
why i thought you're the prime minister
you've got to be honest about this
where's the integrity just say you you
decided that on balance you were going
to appoint him and you didn't and then
there was the absolute bombshell from um
gary sanbrook that the prime minister
was effectively gaslighting his own mps
saying um it's your fault for letting
him get so drunk when you know he's he
of somebody who was alleged to have um
committed a sexual assault but it's just
got to the point sophie where um there
are serious issues going on in this
world we're at war in europe that's
relating to
inflation pressures at home and all
we're talking about is this and i have
to say i find it incredulous to see a
statement saying that the prime minister
and the chancellor will be laying out an
economic plan tomorrow because if they
think there's going to be any other
question then mr rohari did you tell the
prime minister to resign last night then
i think they've just completely lost the
plot
you were talking about the integrity of
boris johnson the prime minister do you
feel that you can trust what he says do
you feel that he's a liar
well i mean clearly what's been shown
over the last 48 hours is that
for whatever reason it is people are
being sent out with a message and then
in my most generous mood i can say that
the prime minister is recalling that
that wasn't quite um right and then
saying um
a new line and of course i'm talking
about and the whole instant about did he
know about chris pincher or not and i
think that this just speaks to a bigger
issue of what where's the concentration
levels here is this about honesty
integrity which i believe you really
have to have honesty integrity when
you're in public office
is it just
basically he doesn't have that control
he doesn't think things through he just
says oh i don't know no i never knew
anything about it and sends people out
there to the slaughter i'm sorry the
problem is it's become a circus and the
circus has to stop and i'm afraid it can
only stop with a new leader
you say it could only start with a new
leader it feels like number 10 are
digging in that the prime minister is
trying to stay
in his job can you see any way that he
survives with the strength of feeling
among the parliamentary party or is it
just a matter of time before he does go
it's just a matter of time now sophie i
i can't believe there's any serious
commentator out there or any um
there's certainly a majority in the
conservative party who thinks it's just
a question of time no serious
commentator is going to come out and say
he's going to survive this and actually
if you look at the vast majority of
people who are flocking to his side
tonight they're people who just know
they wouldn't have a job under any other
prime minister
how many others okay uh thank you very
much for being with us alex shelbrook
really good to talk at interesting
torture thanks sophie
well there you go you can see that alex
shelbrook uh talking about uh how he
believes the party has turned into a
circus we can talk now to our deputy
political editor sam coats you've got
news for us breaking news boris johnson
has sacked
michael gove just confirmed by number 10
the man who scuppered the 2016
leadership bid
ambitions of boris johnson now
fired by boris johnson
earlier today we understand michael gove
told boris johnson he thought his time
was up it appears that boris johnson has
decided that he's not going anywhere
instead it's michael gove who's had to
fall on his sword it's interesting isn't
it because we haven't heard anything
publicly from uh michael grove unlike
some of his other colleagues but as you
say this understanding that he went in
to effectively tell boris johnson the
time was up there's history between the
two men as you alluded to
do we know anything more about um how
the second came about
so we know that michael gove uh went to
boris johnson privately he was trying to
avoid this kind of psychodrama that
became so iconic uh those years ago uh
and instead informed boris johnson that
he didn't think that he could keep going
now it's no secret that boris johnson
and michael gove have increasingly been
at odds on critical issues uh policy
issues uh in recent weeks uh not least
brexit boris johnson are taking a more
robust approach than michael gave was
willing uh to countenance but michael
gove has been by boris johnson's side
since the start and really
campaign the referendum and throughout
the referendum campaign and in
government where he cycled in and out of
the very most inner circle there were
moments where michael gove was making
absolutely critical decisions on things
like covid restrictions and things like
that but over time uh michael goff of
course is in the department for leveling
up a department created effectively for
him uh the two have uh parted ways uh
increasingly michael gave uh
sounding less and less happy uh to
allies now what's critical uh is that
michael gove went first but he's not the
only one to to tell boris johnson to go
so there's a question about what next i
can also reveal um sophie that there is
one more resignation to come if if
michael gove i am told by senior
downstream sources was a sacking there
is also a resignation now the person i
just spoke to didn't give the name but
we know a large number of people who
went in there to tell boris johnson the
time is up some of whom as they say as
they said to me had letters in their
pocket so any number of contenders
tonight is not over in terms of big news
but at the moment michael gove is out so
when james duddridge issued that
statement to disguise john craig
referring to the fact that there are big
um uh appointments big ministries of
state uh that will uh be filled with new
uh office holders tonight uh presumably
the department for leveling up was one
of the uh departments he was thinking
about but a dramatic moment for this
government it's a big regular nation
isn't it let's make no bones about it
you know that this is not a junior
minister to be sacked this is a big big
moment with michael gave even if the two
men have drifted apart and i guess my
question to you is is there a point when
it becomes difficult for boris johnson
to actually fill some of the roles
that are becoming vacant yes as a prime
minister in number 10 but at the minute
it doesn't really feel like there's much
of a government
well it depends how far down the
parliamentary ranks bluntly boris
johnson is prepared to go in order to
fill uh the senior jobs with the promise
of more money and great prestige but the
risk of a hit to reputation let's be
blunt about it for joining boris
johnson's government there will be some
in the
360 odd conservative mps uh willing to
take the call from the prime minister he
is after all the prime minister he's
insisting he's going nowhere that comes
with the trappings of office it's a
chance to serve your country a lot of
people would be torn over that the
matter of resignation and serving your
country not a simple uh issue uh for uh
many many mps so i think that there is
um i don't think that i think there are
probably
people willing but i think the quality
of the names
might start um might might start to you
might see people with less experience
but we it's clear that we're on the
precipice of
quite a defining cabinet shake-up
because if you've got uh nadine zahali
potentially staying in post the big
question next i suppose is if pretty
patel the home secretary said that she
thinks that boris johnson should go as
there have been reports then does that
also qualify for the sack we also know
that grant shaps told boris johnson that
he
thought his time was up now critically
about grant chat he's another inner
circle figure who has been by boris
johnson's side all the way through
uh and effectively helped fight that
first vote of no confidence has had that
spreadsheet his own private spreadsheet
famous spreadsheet famous for his own
leadership campaign absolutely famously
predicting within one or two what uh
what the number was going to be of np so
we're going to vote in that first vote
in their conferences grant shaps is
saying you don't have the numbers prime
minister that's a pretty big moment just
because of the loyalty grant shacks has
shown
up until this point uh but do these
people having gone in prepared to
threaten uh their resignation uh then
follow through with that threat or in
the face of boris johnson staring them
down and what we understand is boris
johnson is making a very punchy argument
he is saying i'm going nowhere you're
going to have to drag me out sure there
are parliamentary processes that we can
use but i'm i'm intending to reboot the
party two things i think uh are gonna
happen you're gonna have uh a reshuffle
but you're also gonna have this dangling
uh by boris johnson of an economic plan
that is code for the kind of tax cuts
that so many conservatives wanted but
rishi sunak wasn't keen on when he was
chancellor because that would have mean
basically borrowing
to fund them uh now with richie sunak
gone effectively
can nadine zahawi start spraying public
money in order to shore up boris johnson
and bluntly nadine zahari not a man
without ambition uh of his own so could
we see actually the
um
the economic direction of this country
starting to alter in favor of something
even more populist boris johnson
questioned on this of course earlier
today at the liaison committee didn't
deny that we could see a bit of a change
of direction it's interesting isn't it
because it's very difficult not to look
through the lens of all of this uh about
who could be the next leader to take
over from boris johnson because yes he
is defined he says he's not going
anywhere but of course as everyone knows
it may not be his decision at the end if
the 1922 committee do convene to change
the rules and so on so let's talk about
leadership for a bit shall we uh we saw
of course such a javed give what sounded
to many like a leadership pitch in his
resignation speech earlier today we
talked about nadim zahawi uh michael
gaber is a bit of an operator isn't he
and perhaps his own leadership ambitions
may have been quashed but he certainly
strikes me as the kind of man who now is
on the back ventures could be involved
in some of the maneuverings that are
almost certainly going on
yes because there's been so much turmoil
over really that all the years back to
2016 there are an awful lot of king
makers uh on the conservative back
benches michael gove is one he's well
connected in parts of the party of
course uh legit contender himself gavin
williamson probably not in the race but
again will be seen as somebody pulling
strings behind
the scene um but when you get to it
there's a question uh about who the main
contenders might be nadine sahari i
think is one uh but you've also got a
question who will represent the right
could that be uh potentially so well a
brave man steve baker was today talking
about throwing his hat in the ring and
then from the other wing of the party
jeremy hunt former health secretary also
a leadership contender although he
wouldn't do that well recent polling
suggests um when we get to this contest
it's going to be a huge field it's going
to be incredibly messy to find the
direction the conservative party that's
possibly why we do have some nerves
about mps pressing the button and going
into it fascinating stuff sam thank you
very much for bringing us that a
breaking news uh sam coates there uh
with the line uh that michael gove has
been sacked uh from the cabinet leveling
up secretary like michael gove sacked
by boris johnson and potentially another
resignation to come we can talk now to
our next guest bob seeley another
conservative mp who is making it clear
today that he wants the prime minister
to resign he is the mp for the isle of
wight she joins us now live thank you
for being with us first of all your
reaction please michael gove has been
sacked by the prime minister
uh well it's it's not a boring day in
politics it's a an exciting and
interesting day uh i've literally just
seen the news and i was thinking oh my
god what am i going to say when you ask
me the question so i'm not quite sure
i i think
unfortunately this is all part of an
endgame and i don't see any way out of
it
apart from boris very sadly stepping
down in the coming days because
otherwise i think there will be another
vote i voted for boris last time i voted
for him in two out of the three rounds
of the leadership election
and i and i'm really sorry it's come to
this but i i can't see any other way out
because we need to have a new leader we
need to have a new government uh with a
new agenda because we'd have to deal
with the very significant problems our
country is facing and people are not
going to forgive us if we indulge in
sort of endless uh fighting amongst
ourselves so this needs to happen sooner
rather than later we need to get a new
leader in place quite quickly and then
we need to move on
it's interesting because you say that
you know conservative mps won't be
forgiven for indulging in continued
infighting it's very similar to the line
that boris johnson the prime minister is
giving for the reason that he wants to
stay in office it does feel like he's
digging in and he's saying that it would
be effectively indulgent to replace him
he wants to get on with the job i mean
do you think that he has a point
no i don't agree with great respect to
him because the noise is off and the
noises and all the ethical questions
coming out of downing street it just
distracts from the business of
government and the one thing that is
affecting every single person who is
watching your programs is the 10
inflation everyone is going to be poorer
next year because of that you know there
are significant cost of living crisis
um covert has still had a profound
impact on our society the war in eastern
ukraine is having a
profound impact all these things are
very important to our future and yet
everything seems to be coming second to
ethical questions around the prime
minister i voted for the prime minister
in the vote of confidence a month ago
because i was hoping that would draw a
line under it i was still willing to
give him the benefit of the doubt and
i'm afraid to say that i think the chris
pincher affair has really
uh i think it has been you know the
final straw for quite a lot of people
and clearly for
lots of ministers as well who've been
resigning today
yeah as you say it has been quite an
extraordinary
day we're taking a step back 39
ministers and aids resigning yeah he's
obviously lost
i'm quite glad
as well i'm just going to pause at now
because we believe we've got two more
resignations have come in uh james
bailey uh his
apologies james daley has also uh
resigned and also david mundell has
resigned we could bring uh sam coates in
at this uh point shall we two more uh
resignations i think that makes it 41 in
total that's right now these are people
at slightly lower end of the ministerial
run without being too rude to them uh
james daley is a pps a ministerial aide
at the department of work and pensions
he's released his letter to the prime
minister uh saying due to recent events
has become very clear that we'll sadly
that you're sadly unable to lead our
government and deliver on policies uh
that will change the lines for better uh
and create opportunity for all the other
figure to have gone uh is uh david
mundell now he's a trade envoy they're
the kind of cross-party uh figures uh he
was trade envoy to new zealand i can see
that being something of a wrench he of
course used to be uh scottish secretary
training for quite a nice role you're
going uh quite a lot of travelling a lot
of uh soft diplomacy so uh uh so um i
think that will be uh quite clear um
you've now we're now in the phase where
boris johnson is both making
dramatic and in some cases tough
decisions uh but also downing street and
boris johnson's allies are trying to get
out messages defensive messages to show
that boris johnson uh is on top of
things not just at the mercy of events
nadine doris of course one of the chief
uh supporters of boris johnson in
cabinet has just uh put this message on
social media she says the prime
minister's priority is to stabilize the
government set a clear direction for the
country and continue to deliver promises
that he and the british public voted for
so there is a little bit of a concession
in that nadine dory's message that
perhaps there isn't a great deal of
stability uh that there isn't quite the
kind of direction that they would like
at the moment which is pretty
extraordinary uh for an ally of the
prime minister to admit here we are
almost three years into boris johnson's
time in downing street and for uh one of
his top allies to say oh we haven't
quite got the direction certain now
clearly they would say people have
pushed them off course rebels have
pushed them of course uh uh but uh
but uh nevertheless that's the message
they're putting out tonight interesting
stuff thank you very much sam and it
does really feel doesn't it
that it is this process of even the more
junior resignations leading
to an impression that it can be very
very difficult for boris johnson to form
and maintain a government let's have a
quick more a little bit more with bob
seeley at shall we who's been waiting
patiently for us uh while we did that
breaking news so thank you for that
uh just finally
it feels like boris johnson is digging
in extraordinarily in some ways because
he's lost so many members of his
government what happens next week if the
prime minister refuses to resign
i think there will be a new round of
elections i think the rule so there will
be another vote of confidence the rules
will be changed probably there will be a
quite a few maybe several dozen people
like myself who voted for the prime
minister last time who would probably
not vote for him this time sadly so i
suspect the numbers will go up from 148
undoubtedly probably to over 200 so
between 200 250 is my guess
but i suspect he will be sadly defeated
on that and
i i'm wondering for him it would be
better to go earlier and so we can move
to get a hustings to get our candidates
the last two candidates uh whittle that
process down and present those
candidates to the conservative party
preferably maybe even before recess
because we need a new direction and we
need to we need to move on
from where we are now we have really
important work to do internationally uh
nationally and on the isle of wight as
well uh and we need a government focus
to be able to deliver that new agenda so
it's a positive time potentially but
we've just got to overcome a couple of
hurdles and then we need to get back to
the business of governing and reminding
people why we had that 80 seat majority
in the first place and i'm sure
because there are a lot of very talented
potential leaders that we can do that
and do that quickly
to do it and to do it quickly as you say
you would need the prime minister to
effectively step down it does feel like
what is happening behind number 10
tonight is critical with members of the
cabinet and what would you say
to cabernet members who are perhaps
wrestling
right now with their consciences whether
they should resign or not what would
your message to them be
um what's that line for macbeth um if it
were done to weren't done quickly i i
think i think the party has now moved i
think the party has made up its mind i
think the party is uh undoubtedly going
to ask boris or not give boris its
support when there is going to be
another vote so i i think for the sake
of boris's reputation i would look at
stepping down sooner rather than later
because i do not think he will win a
vote of confidence sadly that would give
us the opportunity to move on and get
another leader whether it's saaj or
rishi or penny or liz but we've got a
lot of very good candidates and we know
we've got an important job to do we know
we're the right party to do it because
the labour party is not fit for
government
um and we need to get out there and show
leadership and show
you know perseverance determination and
all the other things that we are known
for
and we need to get back talking to the
british people about the things that
matter for them because everybody
listening to this program is being
affected by the cost of living crisis by
the inflation potentially by the war in
eastern europe because it is very
dangerous and we shouldn't be
normalizing what's happening we need a
government that's relentlessly focused
on the isle of wight i need people
delivering i need ministers delivering
for my agenda here and we're not going
to get that with the endless noises off
and the ethical questions that sadly
we've had we had the chance to draw a
line under it and sadly because of the
chris pincher effect has not worked so
we need to move on and we need to get a
new leader with a new vision a new
agenda a new government and a new chance
to rebuild our relationship with the
british people
okay thank you very much for uh being on
the program uh this evening bob's gonna
be there talking to us from a very
picturesque looking uh isle of wight
well we can talk now to our chief
political correspondent uh john craig
who is in westerns for us this evening
uh john i think you're joined by
somebody
sophie i'm joined by james duddridge one
of the prime minister's parliamentary
private secretaries who gave us a
statement a short time ago talking about
the pm being buoyant and so on and
fighting on and planning to unveil an
economic plan along with his new
chancellor james duddridge is uh with me
now mp for rochefort and south and west
been uh mr dodgers you've been with the
pm all day
you said in your statement he's buoyant
is he really boying he is point he's up
for a fight and he knows it's going to
be difficult but he asked me to leave
him uh down the street come over here
tell members of parliament that he's
listened but he's up for a fight he's
going to make some changes he's going to
make some cabinet appointments today i
wasn't in on the meeting but i'm told he
sank michael gove
there's a number of other appointments
to be made he
will be engaging with that you know
today as we we go through nadeem sir
hawaii's uh solidly behind him uh so
reports there were wrong he's going to
announce a new uh economic strategy
that's going to happen sometime next
week but as a tax-cutting conservative
i'm really pleased to say that there
will definitely be tax cuts uh in that
speech i don't know the details we'll
have to wait for that but that is the
red meat that the back benches wanted
we're going to seize him coming out
fighting making some changes making tax
cuts and moving forward he's got a 14
million mandate from the british public
he now needs to deliver that now is not
the time to have a stupid election and
look introverted this is a time to worry
about the issue of ukraine to get the
tax cuts to get the economy back on
track and move forward and he really is
up for it i think a lot of people might
say the red meat is the sucking of
michael gove i mean you slip that in
there in the middle of your answer as it
was just a minor thing why has he sacked
michael gove i don't know i was i wasn't
i wasn't i have an idea i was going
around saying that michael gove's a
disloyal so-and-so i genuinely don't
know mr gove's become the first person i
can think of to be sacked by three prime
ministers david cameron sacked him as
education secretary theresa may sacked
him when she became prime minister and
now boris johnson my night job is not to
be disrespectful of colleagues um is
simply to pass on the mood of the prime
minister and say what he's he's doing
there were question marks over what he
was going to do after the meetings in
downing street it's been very clear he's
moving forward 14 million now we've
heard the pm talk about that you've
mentioned it a couple of times
that's all very well but the fact is he
doesn't appear to have the support of
many cabinet ministers and we believe a
majority of conservative backbenchers
well it doesn't matter about the 14
million majority
mandate does it surely what matters the
electorate that matters right now is
tory mps and they've turned on him well
yes clearly some have and and the
message for
from many
yeah well that we people
appoint you ministers so there's plenty
of talent within the party well i'm not
going to go through the cabinet
reshuffle but i know that there are
plenty of people keen willing and able
to serve and we'll do so under boris
johnson um brandon lewis we believe has
gone into number 10 is he getting a new
job what's he getting i i i don't know
i'm not in charge of the prime
minister's appointments firing take us
through the prime minister's day because
you said you've been with him all day i
mean who were you i haven't been where
are you
for example when the cabinet minister
said to him time's up boris you've got
to go and i don't recognize the reports
of a cabinet all being in a room with a
prime minister oh so was it one by one i
did i just i i
i wasn't in a meeting i don't know about
that meeting but we've had it confirmed
by senior members of parliament that um
when
i was told by a very very senior mp that
the cabinet went in and said to him
prime minister game's up time to go and
he said no i'm not going that's correct
isn't it i i don't know if that's
correct well i told him no no
i'll tell you what i can only say what i
know yeah um so what i do know is a
number of cabinet people turned up they
had chats with his team they had a chat
with him um at various points um and he
made it clear that he was fighting on
why are you staying loyal well because
boris johnson is right for the country
and right for the party i mean he's got
an electoral uh magic that he showed as
mayor of london i believe he'll deliver
brexit i believe he's uh the best person
still i mean no one's perfect and
clearly he has made some mistakes um but
he can move on from this and one of the
things the parts we want are tax cuts
and i think that's really going to
reassure people um we didn't see much
electoral magic in
tiverton and honest and wakefield before
that shropshire north i mean it seems to
be the three p's have done for him
patterson partygate and now pincher and
he's made a right hash of all three
hasn't he well mid midterm we always
lose by elections
more recent ones are uh are an anathema
in many ways we're back to business as
usual people are done people are going
back to business as usual businesses in
relation to violence we've got about 40
40 ministers from ranging from senior
cabinet ministers to parliament i was
just talking about by-elections oh okay
but it's not business as usual is it
well
there's a mood must be a mood of crisis
in downing street you say that but there
is business as usual things happening
the prime minister has been signing he's
spoken to international leaders
that is business as usual there is the
business to be getting on with he has
consulted with his cabinet he's staying
and he's taking things forward you
haven't even got enough ministers for
dcms questions and attorney general's
questions tomorrow one of the dcs
ministers has quit and the solicitor
general's quote are you telling me
they're going to be replaced tonight
there's going to be some major
appointments made tonight i don't know
whether that i don't think they'll all
be made tonight i mean it's 10 o'clock
so that that that is unlikely now danny
kruger son of the famous tv chef
um he's going to leave a sour taste in
number 10 because he's just quit what
about that
what was danny kruger doing he's quit
because of mike
sorry i mean he's not a minister but
he's a pps oh right sorry well i mean
pps is i say this as a pps it's the
lowest form of a promotion it's an
unpaid role helping your boss now mr
kruger is saying it should be the prime
minister going not mr gove
but i mean don't danny i spoke to danny
today um and and passed on the message
to the prime minister that he thought he
should go and there are people that
think he should danny's one of them um
that's a perfectly uh understandable
view for some people to have i don't
agree with that there's a number of
colleagues that don't agree with that
and the prime minister thinks that he
can go on and deliver and get those
numbers you talked about appointments
tonight you're expecting more sackings
tonight
um
i've not heard any a talk of anyone
being sacked as i say the the news about
michael gove was was news to me i wasn't
on that just going back to mr gove i
mean that is a major move by the prime
minister and clearly he believes that mr
gove
is either he's making a mess of leveling
up
or
he's disloyal treacherous he wasn't in
pmqs as far as we can see he hasn't been
acting as a cheerleader for the prime
minister so presumably mr gove has been
sacked for disloyalty that was why
theresa may sacked him after all she
said go on to go to the back benches and
learn how to be loyal
if it wasn't for michael's actions which
he now regrets uh boris would have been
a leadership candidate and remained in
and probably would have gotten instead
of theresa may so you think that mr gove
is disloyal to boris johnson well where
he had been dislodged boris johnson he
regrets that decision then i i can't
speak for today
okay mr dudridge thank you very much
very quick reaction for if i may from
stuart jose is with us the smp mp
michael gove gone another a lot less
scottish voice around the cabinet table
i don't think the fact of his
scottishness would actually change his
politics i have to say i i don't rate
michael gove quite as much as michael
golf rates himself but many in the tory
party do think he's a big beast i think
that's quite the thing it actually
speaks to the utter dysfunction of this
government tonight thank you very much
for a quick reaction there from stuart
jose so thank you very much to james
duddridge a very candid interview there
about what's going on inside number 10
the thinking behind mr gove sacking and
the prime minister's defiance fighting
on and ready to introduce a new economic
plan with his new chancellor nadim
zahari back to you sophie
okay thank you uh very much uh john
craig john there
talking uh to james doddridge there
supporting the prime minister saying
that he's really up for it uh he's going
to be appointing new ministers and
there's going to be a new economic
strategy next week of course during that
interview as so often has happened today
we've had yet another resignation a
junior resignation admittedly but danny
kruger there uh the parliamentary
private secretary uh resigning uh as a
result perhaps of the sacking of michael
gove that has dramatically happened
in the last
hour
now earlier today at prime minister's
questions perhaps the most dramatic
question it came from one of the prime
minister's own the conservative mp tim
lawton
let's have a quick listen to the
question
does the prime minister think there are
any circumstances in which he should
resign
[Applause]
uh
i think mr speaker clearly if the uh if
there were circumstances in which i felt
it was uh impossible for the government
to go on and discharge uh the mandate uh
that we've been given uh or if i felt
for instance that we're being frustrated
in our desire to support the ukrainian
people or over some major points
but but frankly mr speaker the job of a
prime minister in difficult
circumstances when he's been handed a
colossal mandate is to keep going and
that's what i'm going to do
can now speak to the concert of mp for
east worthing and showroom at tim lawton
live
with us uh now thank you for being on
the programme well you asked a question
to the prime minister since then we've
had yet more resignations a sacking
we've had members of the cabinet going
into number 10 demanding that the prime
minister resign
he hasn't
it is like he is digging in uh what do
you think the answer to your question is
do you think there are any circumstances
where the prime minister might resign
well i i don't know and that's why i
asked the prime minister i didn't get a
very good answer and can i just say
sophie i really do sympathize with james
duddridge who is a fantastic colleague
and to be sent out by number 10
to give kamiko ali a run for his uh
money is is pretty poor and defending
the the indefensible the game is up and
i didn't take any joy in asking that
question uh today but it needed to be uh
to be asked and that crack in the dam we
saw last night when uh sajid and rushi
handed their notice has now become a
huge hole
in the dam with a succession of very
talented ministers
deciding that enough is enough today and
the prime minister really needs to
acknowledge that not trying to tough it
out because frankly it's now we're now
in the end game and he needs to
acknowledge that he needs to resign with
the dignity on his own uh terms and we
can all say thank you very much and then
get on with the job of electing a new
leader and a new prime minister which is
what we need to do urgently
you mentioned the interview that we just
heard with james duddridge he obviously
has a different view he thinks that
actually they can appoint new ministers
there's plenty of people who are ready
to serve there'll be a new economic
strategy next week and tax cuts what's
the problem
i don't believe james believes that i
mean it's just completely delusional a
large chunk of government and
particularly some really talented
ministers who had every expectation of
progressing and making it into the into
the cabinet i have said to boris what
i've been saying for many uh months now
and others around me
that his position is untenable and that
has come to a head at last thank god it
has come to a head because it was
completely distracting government from
getting on with the job of government
which is what we desperately need to get
back to uh
to to doing and so the game is up he
can't replace all those holes in the in
the government with other people because
frankly i think he'd really
struggle to find people who would now
want to serve in his government because
it's going to be a very short-term
appointment because frankly
he will have to go one way or the other
in the next few days i hope he does the
honourable thing and resigns on his own
terms but if not
then the 1922 committee executive will
change the rules next week and we'll
have another vote of confidence and as
bob seeley said earlier to you i've
absolutely no
doubt that there will be a not
insignificant majority now saying sorry
prime minister but we don't have the
confidence in you anymore and if we
would have a very different result to
just a few weeks ago
it's interesting let's unpick that a bit
the 1922 committee who can call a
confidence uh motion if enough letters
go in but of course they do need to
change the rules first to allow boris
johnson to face a second confidence
motion after he survived the first one
how quickly do you think this could all
happen they're obviously meeting to
elect the new officials on monday
well it could happen and it needs to
happen very quickly so what the 22
committee executives have decided and
they have a lot of power in this they
run the whole election uh procedures
they've and i think sensibly decided
that given we have elections annual
elections for the 22 executive which is
due to happen in the next few weeks that
it should be for the new committee to
decide if there's to be a rule change
because that's a big move and it's not
something i would like to see done uh
lightly so they've brought forward the
elections to monday so on on monday all
the nominations will be in
every conservative mp will have a vote
we will elect a new
uh executive committee of the 1922
and they will then decide whether they
want to change the rules and they'll do
so i think with a very
fresh and credible mandate having just
been elected to those positions so
people can't cry foul to say it was you
know they haven't got a mandate to do
well they will have a brand new
mandate and if they decide there needs
to be a new vote of confidence which is
i think they will
then we can vote as early as monday
evening or tuesday
and if that comes up with a vote of no
confidence the prime minister's i very
strongly suspect it will then a
leadership challenge and a legit
competition can be put into place very
quickly and it all frankly needs to
happen before the summer recess in just
a few weeks time
before the final two contenders as it
works within a party structure can then
go out for the vote of the membership at
large in the in the country and i think
that process needs to be revisited
because it can take several months we
haven't got several months we need to
get on with this we need to have a new
leader a new prime minister getting
government back in the business of
running government
let's talk about that potential uh
leadership election shall we because it
did feel as if one of the reasons that
perhaps people
stayed their hands if you like at the
last vote was because there was no clear
challenger to the prime minister do you
think that has changed do you think
there are serious contenders now and is
there anyone that you would particularly
point to is having a good
chance at getting the top job
well there are serious uh contenders you
know it isn't like you know back in the
time mrs thatcher that was michael
hesden who was uh circling uh with great
ambitions to be uh to be leader there
are and perhaps rishi sunak was a very
strong uh contender but recent events
have rather blotted his copybook i think
very unfairly actually but i could reel
off
a list of half a dozen or more names of
of good competent credible candidates
who uh could easily step up for the
leadership and could easily fit into the
shoes of a prime minister they'll be
very different prime minister
uh to um boris johnson frankly anybody's
gonna be a very different prime minister
boris johnson but that's not to say they
can't do the the job at least as well if
not uh if not better
and just finally uh while we've got you
the big news this night tonight is the
sacking of michael j gove what is your
reaction to that
well i mean that's pretty serious i've
worked for mate with michael gove for
many uh years and it's it's no great
secret that i'm not the biggest fan of
uh of michael gove but michael gave has
been
despite
some
incidents in the past leadership uh uh
competitions he's been very much at the
side of uh of boris and boris has been
listening to him so for boris to
turn around and when i think it was
michael gove who went to number 10 with
the
uh the metaphorical bottle of whiskey in
the revolver uh well clearly boris is
down the whiskey and turn the revolver
and michael uh michael gave who would
have believed it
pretty uh dramatic i mean you couldn't
write the script to be honest over the
last few days it does feel like that tim
lorton very good to speak to you
as always thank you for being on the
programme
well it has been an extraordinary
few days here in downing street the news
of course continued to come throughout
the program with the sacking of michael
gove we can talk now to uh sam just to
get a bit of a round up of where we are
um
obviously the light's still on in that
building it feels like they'll be still
on for a little while yet as the prime
minister thrashes out his future
how
serious do you think some of the kind of
cabinet machinations are or do you think
boris johnson has bought himself at
least a few more days
the fight for boris johnson's future
goes on unresolved tonight he's trying
to get back on the front foot there is
the sacking of michael gove there is
dangling of tax cuts by james duddridge
just now uh in front of the
parliamentary party if they keep uh
boris johnson uh in place nadine zahari
likely to spray public cash around
and then there is the promise of yet
more from boris johnson reshuffle coming
later tonight so he is trying to regain
momentum look strong by some very
aggressive uh briefing particularly
against michael
by michael gove uh but also just
generally uh look like he's back on the
front foot but
sophie the numbers always determine the
future in politics you can do all the
briefing you can look like you're on the
front foot as much as you want but
consider today's raw figures 42 people
have left government one person michael
gove has been sacked there are 120 or
more conservative mps who since
yesterday have come out and made clear
they have no confidence in boris johnson
many of them restating it now that's 120
plus out of 358 so a third of the
parliamentary party in public are saying
no to boris johnson in private that
number is higher some people choosing
not to do all of this stuff in front of
the cameras unprecedented that a prime
minister could continue in post uh with
that kind of weight of opposition
but the question
is if boris johnson isn't going to go
can they drag him from office and that
question might only be determined next
week you see this is what i'm interested
in you know you're talking about the
question there
but can they drag him from office being
determined next week and this of course
is the 1922 committee changing the rules
having another confidence motion we know
that they can change the rules we know
that they've gone in to tell boris
johnson that they're prepared to do that
we also know that if the rules aren't
changed it is almost certain that boris
johnson loses
so why wait out why the determined
language why not resign is it because
that he would prefer to be dragged from
office rather than resigning well it's
funny enough you say that that is
exactly what allies of boris johnson say
is in his mind he wants almost
the journalist in him the performer in
him wants the
the kind of impression the public of him
being pulled from office against his
will the many grey suits coming for him
and the whole of the party coming for
him because i think at the end that
would be something quite unlike anything
else we've seen in british politics
if he goes if he was to walk away
tonight there's no doubt he would be
remembered for having crashed and burned
the end of his career in failure this
provides some drama maybe just a change
in the way that some of the history uh
the history books might look at him
because remember remember margaret
thatcher's resignation in the end it was
political pressure rather than a formal
mechanism that got rid of her remember
david cameron chose to go
out of his own volition rather than
because of a formal mechanism theresa
may could potentially see the end but
chose to go
in a dignified way boris johnson looks
if he is gonna exit from government like
he's choosing a different path i can't
remember a time where a prime minister
was forced out
not by the electors but but against his
will and like you say the man who is all
about the the script he's all about the
narrative thinking about his own legacy
how he'll be remembered really
interesting stuff and i guess that is
the perhaps the explanation uh thank you
very much uh for all your analysis uh
sam coats well a very
different take for us this evening live
here from downing street it's been
dramatic uh resignations are going on as
we've been on air a sacking two of
michael gove the man who has been at the
side of boris johnson
for many years even if the two men of
course have drifted apart more recently
he is the definition of a big beast and
the leadership candidates now
circling what's the best move for them
is it to do such as javits and to stand
up against boris johnson is it to do in
a doom zaharween perhaps spray some tax
cuts around uh next week to try and win
over uh the uh base uh it would be very
uh interesting uh to try and work out
the different tactics uh that will uh be
used uh there
all eyes now on what happens next week
with that 1922 committee coming up we
will have lots more news for you here
live from downing street anna botting
is up next with the news at 10.
[Music]
you